vi faccio vedere come abbiamo passato
gli ultimi giorni all'ultra music
festival e poi è successo che ho trovato
veramente un telefono per terra non vi
prendo per il culo non vi sto prendendo
per il culo
adesso vi spiego tutto ultra music
[Musica]
ragazzi che cosa è successo
ma cosa fai
[Musica]
cosa sta facendo giuseppe perché va a
[ __ ] giuseppe
basta
macché
[Applauso]
niamey
sì
basta
messa
[Musica]
la figlia
si no
un uomo
[Musica]
dai foto foto
adesso andate tutti salvatore cela lungo
ma buongiorno
sembra che io dietro abbia il paradiso
ma in realtà è l'unico giorno di solito
ho visto in giappone da quando siamo
arrivati perché è un miracolo che la
mattina seguente del giorno in cui siamo
andati all'ultra music festival che sono
attualmente le 10 46 20 ore di musica a
palla nelle orecchie che scolpiscono poi
il risultato sono i miei video ci siamo
divertiti un sacco e volevo parlarvi di
una roba che è successa la cosa ci sono
i festival non c'è tanta gente che esce
siccome c'è una folla immensa se ti
dovesse cadere qualcosa dalle tasche non
te ne accorgi perché c'è troppa gente
c'è un fiume di gente 9 di manco per
terra e mentre ero in mezzo a questo
fiume di gente ieri per terra ho visto
questo per caso non è il mio telefono
telefono e questo io non è che l'iphone
è un samsung
ho trovato un iphone credo sia un iphone
7 credo perché non di non ho mai avuto
un iphone quindi non eder i picchetti
che iphone sia per terra ho trovato nay
phone 7 per terra c'è talmente tanta
gente che straccia che veramente ci
vuole un attimo perché un più di
telefono scivoli dalle tasche infatti
fatto attenzione sono andate a concerti
o robe del genere
mettete sempre in tasche che sapete che
sono sicuro perché se no la fiat e inter
culla quindi ho trovato questo
bellissimo telefono rosa
solo che l'ho trovato scarico quindi
sono tornato a casa sono andati a caso
l'altro giorno durante la notte l'ho
messa in carica e stamattina lo acceso
parte il fatto che c'è il codice di
riconoscimento ovviamente tutto in
giapponese perché aveva perso un ragazzo
anzi una ragazza giapponese infatti se
vedete le scritte sono tutte tutte
quante in giapponese perché ovviamente
proprietari giapponese segni giappone
era difficile nella schermata principale
trovo milioni di notifiche in giapponese
online tra l'altro che il whatsapp
giapponese per dato la tipa si intravede
nello sfondo che tipo commesso a questo
non si sa chi cazzo si sa però vi dico
la verità non è mai successo di trovare
un telefono dal valore di non so quanto
valga adesso hi phone 7
500 600 euro ieri mentre tornavo a casa
che era spento e quindi non potevo
chiamare il tipo non potevo chiamare lo
stesso perché bloccato però mentre
tornavo a casa pensavo tranne mese
riconsegnarlo o meno perché è facile
dire anche il telefono per terra lo
riconsegna sipro trovarlo veramente poi
vedi che ti parte una controversia
interminabile ho deciso di portarlo
anche perché non ha senso che comunque
sia io in primis
ho pensato che se dovessi perdere un
telefono sarà il primo a volerlo
ricevere e non ci spererei mai salutate
tutor che entro tenuta non ci starei mai
di trovare il mio telefono se lo perdo
ad un festival vorrei che mi venisse di
consegnato anche se una catapecchia
ormai anche perché c'é l'adesivo della
sabre game più che altro per lo scazzo
di tutti i numeri di telefono salvati
tutte le foto tutte le cose personali
non è che mi venisse consegnato quindi
ho pensato a ciò che vorrei che venisse
ha fatto a me e prova a farlo per gli
altri
dopo questo se non arriviamo a 5 milioni
di iscritti entro fine giornata
siete degli stronzi quindi ragazzi ho
deciso oggi pomeriggio di portarlo alla
polizia giapponese che tanto vi assicuro
che in mezza giornata la tipa ce l'avrà
indietro perché si fa piuttosto si si
vendono la famiglia per riportarli
quindi oggi voglio essere un po
giapponese anche io e riconsegniamo
questo bellissimo icon7 dal valore
dispiaciuto è una cosa triste che
comunque l'ho trovato all'interno di
questa cover che c'è non so se avete
presente che cover di merce però una
cosa fighissima c'è un tasto qua dietro
di se tu fai così ti illumina la faccia
per i self in giappone ragazzi il futuro
però almeno abbiamo fatto il click day
con questo video è almeno quello che
cazzo ne da lesbici
o come come si vede è questa roba che
non sia vero allora e 5 secondi questo
così diventati costitutivi passo quello
che io non capisco perché se teniamo
portiamo qualche mi conosco in italia
con gli alleati ma per fare al massimo
se non funziona ci vediamo i pezzi
[Musica]